authentique et envoûtant félicitations
vous venez d'être nommé compagne de
l'ordre des arts et des lettres du
québec qu'est ce que ça signifie pour
vous c'est très content je suis très
fier je vais le dire je suis très fier
aussi parce que c'est pas un prix
nécessairement pour moi mais c'est un
prix qui est donné presque à mon peuple
a les autochtones en général alors c'est
comme ça que je le vois à l'heure c'est
doublement à fierté
[Musique]
vous êtes né en 1967 à salou est une où
naviguent l'identité vraiment au coeur
de votre démarche artistique parce que
vous invitez adopté puis leur tout jeune
vous vouliez devenir journaliste par la
suite
artiste ce que c'est toujours le
mouvement perpétuel qui vous nourrit qui
vous forçant fait repousser vos limites
artistique ans quelle que soit je pense
qu'ils vont ensemble moi j'ai vraiment
l'impression que la la la la que
j'exprime va vraiment avec cette quête
constante de de trouver l'équilibré
il ya quelque chose très brute qui est
en moi mais il ya aussi cette calme
aussi qui vient du fait que j'ai été
élevé par des gens qui étaient en partie
des aînés qui sont décédés mais
maintenant mes parents adoptifs puis
alors si j'ai comme une double
personnalité
mais ils vont très bien ensemble c'est
alors je suis pas nier avec se sait
jamais une affaire des faux c'est
fatiguant de faire autant d'intensité et
au temps calme qui est vraiment je
pourrais être heureux n'importe où en
paix mais c'est comme s'il n'y a pas
cette milieu là des fois j'ai juste
envie que ma vie soit juste pour milieu
mais non c'est cesser de faire fuiter
ces demandes jeu très touché que vous
preniez le temps de me parler parce que
vous êtes hyper occupée par les temps
qui courent où vous en êtes à la
conception d'un nouveau spectacle le
grand seul style sa diffusion le 21
joueurs pour la journée nationale des
autochtones est ici radio canada
peu d'artistes mois nos spectacles
comment vous l'imaginez vous le voyez
cet événement c'est vraiment
extraordinaire de savoir que les gens un
peu partout au québec vont pouvoir
regarder c'est un peu partout même dans
le pays vont pouvoir regarder un show où
c'est strictement univers autochtone et
on a voulu quand même aussi célébrer
cette fête nationale qui est notre fête
nationale qui n'est pas encore reconnue
comme une vraie fête parce que les gens
travaillent encore ces jours là vous
parlez de jour férié de fête nationale
la fête du canada ça s'en vient on me
dit sous-entendre que vous étiez une des
têtes d'affiché de la fête du canada
2021 mais que vous êtes retiré à la
dernière minute que je pense pas que
j'étais la tête d'affiché
je pense que au moment que je devais le
faire il y avait évidemment
215 enfants c'était encore un secret
entre condom n'était toujours pas au
courant puis entre ça il ya aussi ce
spectacle là que je montre alors j'ai
tout simplement décidé que je vais faut
que c'est sûr la fête nationale des
autochtones
même la semaine passée jeu j'étais
tellement déprimé par rapport à ça
évidemment ces enfants là j'ai deux
trois enfants trois ans sept ans à 15
ans je me pose même la question comment
je peux faire un spectacle lumineux
comme la solstice jeu mais voyez pu
aussi loin que le 21 juin
aujourd'hui je vais je vais mieux parce
qu'on se dit on n'a pas le choix que de
faire ça deux utilisé notre notre
possible pour montrer la lumière parce
qu'on est déjà en lumière et on
argumente pour la culture autochtone
pour les grandes voix vous en faites
partie
est ce que ça vient qu'une certaine
pression pour vous on est tous des
politiciens même si on veut pas si ça
m'intéresse pas d'être une politicienne
mais à chaque artiste je pense on n'a
pas le choix on était politique
notre notre l'air qu'on respire qu'on
amène à la maison même si on n'est pas
devant la caméra c'est politique juste
notre existence est politique je pense
comme beaucoup d'artistes et le dise oui
il ya une pression mais on n'a pas le
choix on est né avec ça on est né avec
beaucoup de douleur aussi
d'intergénérationnel alors on n'a pas le
choix de de trouver une façon de défaire
de ça alors on a un travail énorme pour
arriver que nos enfants sont heureux
quand ils naissent ils s'appuient merci
pour votre générosité mercinat cormick
étudié l'aller puis l'allemagne a
retissé l'alberta a mis sur l'auteur et
une ligne noire le tatami
c'est le 2 5 milliards versés
[Musique]